I think the most important piece of career
advice I ever received was probably from my
mother who used the phrase, “Be one with
the target.”
And what she meant when she said that was,
when you are engaging in some kind of a high
stakes professional gambit, whether it’s
you’re giving a speech or a presentation
at work or you’re breaking a big story,
if you are fully invested in the goal and
it’s a greater goal than yourself it’s
not about you— there’s a certain kind
of armor in that, and people can attack you
personally (and they certainly do attack me
a lot personally) and they can try to weaponize
whatever they want against you, but if you
are really one with the target and you know
that what you’re doing contributes to goals
that are bigger than yourself and you are
100 percent off of thinking about you and
your self-consciousness and your self-interest
and on thinking about the problem and how
you’re going to make things better through
your work and communicating that to the other
people involved in whatever project you’re
working on, there’s no time to get mired
in the “self” piece of it, in the kind
of self-consciousness and the worry about
self-interest that can, I think, sideline
and distract.
That’s easier said than done.
I don’t always live up to that, but it’s
a great philosophy that I found really useful.